the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
when I was family's prisoner Gaara
tried to save me she's the only one who
tried to save me
he needs me now so why are you still
talking to me what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight and Game
Theory's video today I want to talk
about the fate of Yara Greyjoy but
before I get into the discussion let me
make one more announcement about the new
giveaway before it ends
I am currently giving away the entire a
Song of Ice and Fire book collection if
you would like to enter for a chance to
win there is a link down below in the
comment section or description of the
video you can enter the giveaway up to
five times which will increase your
chances of winning the winner will be
announced in about one week from today
so good luck to everyone that's entered
now let's get started what I really want
to talk about today is what will happen
to your agree join next season I think
she may be able to survive the show but
she might not be fully intact by the
time everything is all said and done
Yara Greyjoy's current whereabouts are a
bit of an unknown unfortunately Yara
Theon and the sand snakes were ambushed
by euron greyjoy while they were at sea
euron greyjoy led what ended up becoming
a vicious attack which resulted in the
deaths of several of the sand snakes but
most importantly he was able to all but
completely obliterate two of Danny's
alliances all aureus and anti insane
were both captured along with Yara
Greyjoy
Theon Greyjoy did have an opportunity to
try and save his sister but his inner
reek took control of his mind body and
soul which led to Theon abandoning his
sister to save himself afterwards ilaria
tyene and Yara were paraded through the
streets of King's Landing and dropped
off at Circe's feet at the foot of the
Iron Throne olaria and Tyne were taken
to the dungeons but Euron wanted to keep
Yara great joy for himself so he took
her with him when he left as of right
now we cannot confirm where Yara is
being held but I would assume you're on
is keeping her very close by having her
chained up on his ship the silence what
you're on Greyjoy actually plans to do
with her is a bit of a mystery but if
you look at Euron's history as a
character you can probably guess what
his intentions are when they took off
with Euron's best ships he did make it
very clear that he wanted to kill his
niece and nephew and now that he has his
hands on you're a Greyjoy it might be
only a matter of time before this
actually happens you also have to
remember what the other iron
warned men said to Filan before they
left to be to Dragonstone when John and
Daenerys decided to travel north
together they all prepared to head out
as soon as possible but Theon stopped
John before he left and this was a big
moment for Theon because I believe he
got that closure he was looking for from
John I think it's safe to say that Theon
has had a bit of an identity crisis ever
since Winterfell became his home he
didn't know whether to be a Greyjoy or a
stark but John told him he was both and
Theon did seem to accept this response
because after all that's what he is he
is a Greyjoy by blood but Ned Stark
wanted to teach him the stark Way of
life
deep down I truly think that is what
Theon wanted to be but he also wanted to
please his father and prove that he was
a man of house Greyjoy but we all know
how that worked out anyways how this
scene ended between John and fian pretty
much set up the remainder of Theon's
character arc because now he knows what
he has to do Theon knows his sister did
risk her life to try and save him so now
it's his turn to do the same thing
besides Theon really has nothing else to
lose at this point anyway so you might
as well go out in a blaze of glory
the only problem is Theon isn't exactly
well-prepared for this mission he knows
what needs to be done but he is
ill-equipped it doesn't look like he has
any ships or enough men and weapons
there were maybe two dozen men standing
on the beach but he has to work with
what he has unfortunately for Theon his
uncle Euron is a complete psychopath and
there's no telling what kind of shape
Yara is currently in when Theon even
suggested that they should get Yara back
this is what one of the men said all of
us chose to follow Yara
left the Iron Islands for Yara she would
never leave one of us behind
we're not leaving her behind the sisters
dead she's not done she's dead even if
you Iran hasn't caught a throat yet
she's dead
she's our queen she's your sister and
you left as you can see not all of the
men were very optimistic about this idea
they all know who you're on is and the
chances of yarra still being alive are
very slim
even if she is still alive she might not
be in one piece for those of you who
haven't read the books you might not be
aware of all the things your own is
capable of doing to other people you got
a glimpse of his wrath when he attacked
their ships but this is only a taste of
the things that may be to come later do
you remember what was said and your own
Greyjoy's very first scene in the show
when you're on is first introduced back
in season six we meet him as Balin
Greyjoy is crossing one of the rogue
bridges at the Iron Islands Baylin was
surprised to see that he was still alive
he had been receiving some disturbing
reports over the years and this is one
of the things that he said
tie me to the mast keep you from jumping
over when the stone passed you cuts out
that top needed silence this was
actually one of the details that was
taken from the books
Euron did actually have the tongues
removed from the men who crewed his ship
and according to him it was simply
because he needed silence then when
Euron led the attack he had the same
thing done to all of the men on Yara and
theone ship this time he wasn't only
cutting out their tongues he was doing
much more than that I have a common geta
as you can see this is something you're
on enjoys doing to his victims and he
just might have done this to Yara as
well even though the TV show has moved
past the books they were still using
some details from the books in season
seven as of right now everyone is still
waiting for the winds of winter to come
out but even though it's not released
yet george RR martin has still released
a handful of sample chapters for his
next book one of those sample chapters
is called the forsaken and Game of
Thrones does appear to be pulling some
information out of this chapter for
Euron Greyjoy current storyline this
does make sense because that's his
current storyline in the books if you
take a look at this chapter it could
give us some clues as to what's to come
for Euron and you're a Greyjoy since she
is his prisoner in the forsaken chapter
Euron has one of his family members held
captive on his ship in the books it's
his brother
but in the show it's Yara in the
forsaken chapter his brother has a
vision of your own sitting on the Iron
Throne with a tall pale woman standing
next to him and we just might see this
happen next season - because your own is
already very close to taking the throne
for himself
especially now that Jaime has gone and
out of his way
so far this new chapter seems to be
heading in the same direction of the
show also in this chapter Euron has
several people bound to the prow of his
ship and that's exactly what we saw
during season seven Euron had both of
the same snakes bound and hung to the
front of his ship so as you can see just
because Game of Thrones moved past the
books doesn't mean they still aren't
using details from them now there is
something else from this chapter that I
want to point out because it could
reveal you're a Greyjoy fate there is
another character Euron has on his ship
in this chapter and this character is a
woman not only is she pregnant but her
tongue was also removed now I don't want
to sit here and say you're on will get
Yara pregnant but this would not be the
first time you're on molested or
sexually assaulted a family member
Euron actually does this to one of his
brothers but since Yara seems to be
taking his place as Euron's prisoner
maybe you're on does something sadistic
like this - Yara she is being held on
the ship called the silence after all so
it's basically a tradition if you're
gonna be on that ship unfortunately for
Yara she might just get a taste of what
it's like to be Theon No
pun intended also if you look at Theon
sample chapter from the ones of winter
there are a few different quotes about
tongues and one of those even mentions
Theon's tongue being removed so I think
it's very possible we can see something
like this next season before I end the
video I want to show you a response from
one of my patreon supporters when I had
the idea to make this video
I left a post on patreon telling them
what the video would be about that way
they could leave me some of their own
thoughts if they would like I want to
read what Shireen had to say because she
felt pretty much the same way
she said Yara will lose her tongue her
favorite plaything Theon will likely die
saving her or finally figure out like
the unsullied that he could be a good
fighter without his favorite toy we have
been hearing about how nobody trusts a
eunuch yet when we meet grey worm we did
feel different I'm thinking he will
regain his honour he has nothing left to
lose but has severe PTSD
Euron is crazy and I think Theon will
find a way out of his misery or if Sansa
survives he will swear his sword to her
he never uses his bow and I wonder if he
will finally remember his weapon of
choice as you have seen in my video
today I pretty much feel the same way
but now I want to know what all of you
have to say about your Greyjoy's fate
put some of your thoughts or questions
down below because I'd like to hear them
I want to thank everyone for watching
the video I appreciate that as always
and I can't forget to thank all of you
kind people on patreon for supporting
the channel I hope you'll have a great
day I'll see you soon bye